mécontent du résultat des élections à
moi je suis complètement rasée mais avec
jack lang
je suis une amie d'un tas de gens de
jacques oui en l'occurrence de tonton
non et puis c'est très content tu es
très sage à des bases ça aide d'être du
côté du manche mais couche gelée était
un moment où ça a été pas du tout les
passages avec le dire
alors aujourd'hui c'est pas et chute du
côté du manche mais ça me fait plaisir
de voir que les gens en qui j'ai
confiance et que j'aime ont gagné entre
guillemets quoi vous ce qu'on gagne et
ne pas faire cocorico contente que ça me
semble ça me fait plaisir dès
l'ouverture tu crois que ça va marcher
c'est pour l'ouverture de ben moi je
suis pour l'ouverture ou également way
to vendée pour le bloc non mais pour le
vertueux il ya longtemps je veux dire
que moi je suis pas aimé président du
coeur que nous il ya des compartiments
du jeu intelligent partout et que
j'espère que l'on va ouvrir on va
arrêter un peu de se séparer comme ça et
qu'il ya un moment on va bien finir par
se retrouver une espèce de second centre
tu penses quoi du paf qui a été mis en
place en 86 a lepage de retard et que
tf1 privatiser la 5
l'a6 etc je suis content ne soit plus là
quoi changer la écoute je trouve que l
époque où lang était là et un passant
qui l'a bhutto
était positif
il assure il a fait beaucoup de choses
je pense que c'est bien qu'il soit venu
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il va se
passer l'option tout va beaucoup la télé
oui les thèmes à la télé le salaire du
zappeur avec wahaha tentateur télé qui
partirait sur l'île deux heures aucun
robert ford dechavanne non drucker j'ai
pas bien quand même genre non mais non
ok je te dis les nuls en ont peut-être
votre menu de cette ligne un petit
week-end sabatier n'ont pas regardé
non non mais coûtent ils sont gentils
ces gens là mais moi j'ai pas envie de
partir en vacances avec eux comme
instance est un peu morose et non plus
non plus et j'aime bien hiver tu sais
pas bien quoi
mais je vais pas envie de partir on va
corriger déserte avec l'ue étant non non
non déjà sur l'île déserte tout seul
j'aurais du mal à partir c'est à dire un
arbitre lors qu maintenant que tu
connais les ragots qui courent sur ton
compte quand même a bon dos ouais après
quoi on dit comme bien lire entre autres
les gels ans non mais moi ça me gêne pas
du tout façon j'ai vu un article du 10 e
match ok t'es matcha et puis un article
de paca dispute interviewé chez toi
c'est un horloge je me disais que
regarder amoureusement une jeune fille
que tu es chez toi là j'ai pas un secret
je veux dire non mais pourquoi il n'y a
pas de problème moi j'aime j'aime j'aime
tout ce qui est beau tout ce qui
m'attire
pas de problème avec ça j'aime les êtres
ouais ouais j'suis pas souhaité pas
envie non plus être dans un tiroir c'est
des mecs ça me donne des boutons et donc
t'as pas ça me semble bien que la
biomasse a priori qua non j'ai aucun a
priori à feu a tiré par les gens qui me
plaisent c'est sympa vraiment tout va
bien la de ce côté là et alors quatre
heures dommage qu'ils canalisent tu as
dit dans un article ouais c'était
l'époque baba je vais je me frisé je
cumule les pétards dans steam encore des
pétards non c'est vrai que j'ai arrêté
au revoir j'ai fait de la période lowen
pis pour le beau temps qui fumait et
sabo qui blessent les pieds enfin j'ai
tout fait la main des tares bien
ouais bah je pense que rien d'abord
j'avais pas envie de mourir idiote va
bien m'essayer à tout essayer
tous sauf l'hérault pascal monde a coupé
tout ça tout de suite arrêter la
cigarette
ouais il ya sept ans ouais il s'entend
que j'ai tout arrêté puis parce que
c'est comme ça c'est un choix parce que
j'avais besoin de retrouver mon énergie
passé une histoire de génération si tu
as quel âge tu dit en quarante deux as
tu le dis ouais ah bon et quand tu étais
petit voulait ressembler acquis pour
personne j'ai jamais eu ça avant
non j'ai des idées j'en ai eu plano ma
vie j'en ai toujours pas ce que c'est
bien dans ces comptes et leader du
groupe u2 plein de gens
il y en a trop je suis groupies de tina
je suis gros fille de sting janis joplin
des shops
ouais j'suis groupies d'un tas de gens
c'est bien tu pouvais changer quelque
chose en toi tu changerais quoi très
grande et blonde les cheveux par exemple
c'est une heure et demie mesure 1 m 56
et demi comme un mec 02 dit c'est 56 et
nous disons oui ça devienne pas
d'opinion tu changerais rien on suit
admis comme du savon de baguette magique
chez pas non mais alors si j'avais une
baguette magique ça doit être marrant
d'être mecs pendant cinq minutes
ouais mais cinq minutes parce que
j'adore être une femme lara son vrai nom
non c'est le nom de ma grand mère étant
vraiment c'est quoi on se le dit pas il
est moindre que celle du jeu god i chez
des contrôles n'ont envie des os est pas
loin et dénonce les 10 pour
l'enseignement pour le monde c'est quoi
ton silence et mon surnom ouais j'en ai
plein gignac être tout katoch il
m'appelait buyema p14 pas très beau il
ya la lie
il ya un kaka il ya avant wec à castres
jolie dans l'intimité on s'appelle
comment dans l'intimité
on appelle ce point fqu enfin étant
c'était un truc à lui ce titre elle
touche à la 4k kapopo à ça je lui en
baisse à lula lors et ben voila enchanté
sinon à quoi voir ça sera la dernière
phrase faveur des corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux